JOANNE STUBBE: The
morphological unit of life
is the cell, whether you're
a flea or you're an elephant.
Right?
And we all have water
as the major solvent.
We all have the same
biological molecules that
play a major role inside our
bodies, like sugar or fat,
or amino acids, or nucleotides.
We all have the same
ways of making reactions
work fast enough so they
can succeed inside the cell,
and controlling the specificity,
and they're conserved
from bacteria to humans.
We all use the same vitamins
on your vitamin bottle.
And those are also
conserved in general
from bacteria to humans.
And we also all have the same
major regulatory mechanisms,
although as you go from
prokaryotes to eukaryotes,
things get more complex.
And so what we cover in
the course is, in fact,
most of the things we talk
about are bacterial systems
because they're better studied
but can be extrapolated
between the two systems.
So are these things
ordered inside the cell?
And how do you study
them inside the cell?
That's the major
focus of a biochemist.
You want to understand things
at the molecular level,
but then you need
to understand what
you see at the molecular level,
how does that relate to what's
going on inside the cell?
And so you need to
go back and forth
between inside the
cell and understanding
the chemical and physical
principles by which all
the reactions work.